the selection of motocross games are few  and far between these days so it's good  to hear that the latest mxgp is a solid  dirt terrain racer with AI team races  tracks with personality among many other  features this clip is a modest sampling  of what mxgp 3 offers with some camera  options and even better a first-place  finish so how excited are you for a  summer of motocross let us know in the  comments below if this footage has you  craving some unpredictable off-road  competition give us a like subscribe to  our Channel  thanks for watching  [Music]  you  [Music]  you  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  you  [Applause]  [Music]  [Music]  you  you  [Applause]